hello everyone I'm alone I'm welcome to
a channel before you start watching this
video I just want to explain kind of
what it is basically a you are watching
a little highlights clip from a full
episode of my podcast red lips orange
car which I've just brought back for
anyone who doesn't know it is a
misconnection slash comedy slash
storytelling podcast we basically dive
into some of the weirdest relationship
stories found on Craigslist
misconnections
or on reddit and discuss them the reason
I decided to go with publishing
highlights here on YouTube rather than
the full podcast is because with my
other podcast which is weekly right now
play watch listen I didn't want to like
flood my channel with podcasts basically
even though this one is only monthly so
unless enough people really want the
full podcast on here I'm probably gonna
keep publishing these like cute little
highlights but you can get the full
episode audio only on pretty much all
podcast services so and it will be out
once a month the second Friday of every
month and ethernal crank gameplays is my
new permanent co-host you'll see him
every episode so yeah enjoy okay am I
the [ __ ] for telling my girlfriend to
get her own copy of Animal Crossing so
around a month ago I 31 mail pre-ordered
the new Animal Crossing game that comes
out next week I've been a huge Animal
Crossing fan since the original 2001
GameCube version well I believe was an
incentive 64 one version and to say that
I'm excited would be an understatement
my girlfriend 23 female lives with me
and she has never been a gamer I've
tried to play games with her but she
just isn't good no concept of defense in
rocket League she can't hold a candle to
me in Smash and the only time she ever
wins in Mario Party is if she gets that
[ __ ] bonus stars I love that because
that's what everyone always says if they
lose Mario Party is that it was a
[ __ ] bonus stars it wasn't
necessarily a point yeah gaming just
isn't her thing which is fine I still
love her do you it's never been an issue
the other day she apparently stumbled
upon YouTube a v2 video of the new
Animal Crossing game and started telling
me how excited she was to play I asked
her if she was going to purchase another
copy and another switch and she was
stunned she asked me why she would need
to get her own when I already
pre-ordered pre-ordered one and I
explained to her that it isn't the type
of game that you share she got all upset
and told me that she thought it would be
cute to live in the same village and be
neighbors and I told her that simply
wasn't the case there's only one and I
don't want somebody who has zero concept
of how the game should actually be
played making decisions that negatively
affect the town I don't want her
stealing exotic fruits from my orchard
oh good that I plan to sell I don't want
her buying furniture from Tom Nook that
I might want to adorn my living room
with yeah and I certainly don't want her
placing her house next to mine because
she thinks it's cute the spoiling what I
plan to develop into a lavish estate
that sentence made me think that maybe
this is what honestly when I read this I
I genuinely thought this cannot be real
lavish sight sounds like horseshit she
told me that it was goat just a game and
she thought we could bond over it but
we've never been able to bond over games
so why start now
that's that ninja suite of being like
saying it's just a game it's such a weak
mindset and my my reply to that got me
blocked by ninja oh yeah I said two
things I made one tweet that just
replaced replaced all the game related
stuff with drawing so if you're not
angry after drawing you've lost twice
and then I also respond saying I'm
fourteen and this is deep and I think I
might have heard the game is bro like
well yeah me too it's like I just like
all lowercase agreed with him so that I
could get all the replies of people
being like I thought you were I think
he's upset well
Lisa's rubber ninja maybe I have no idea
I don't really care ninja of course she
doesn't get that it's a game in which
grinding and planning is key I can't be
prevented from carrying out my vision
simply because she wants to run around
with her dumb ass
pink haired character catching
butterflies or making a const
constellation out of our initials which
I know she would do okay okay so I'm
reading the the that's the thing okay
I'm reading the Twitter cap of this
I think the dumbass pink hair thing was
no it's still there it's still there
dumbass pink hair but to be honest with
you it's saying dumbass pink hair thing
it really makes me think that this man
hates this woman well if she has pink
hair in real life this is enough of an
attack that I feel like they should talk
about it okay so yeah I told her that it
was nothing personnel kid it seems like
it's very personal very personal that I
still love her but she started crying
and told me she doesn't want to play the
stupid game anyway I kind of feel bad
but I also feel like it's unreasonable
for her to just assume she can just
insert herself into one of my passions
without considering how disruptive it's
going to god this guy's an [ __ ] I
make more than her oh oh we're gonna
we're going here I made her so I even
offered to buy her her own console and
game but she said that wasn't the point
and now I'm lost
am I the [ __ ] yes there are some
things to break down here right okay so
yes this is super rude because what
she's asking to do is very sweet and I
think him being labeled you tried to
play games before but he only tried to
play competitive games with her yeah but
he didn't try to do star to valley
didn't dude are you telling this girl
never play videogames who's like tried
to get into it to appease you into
[ __ ] rocket League and then
complaining that her defense isn't good
like also like from my point of view if
if your significant other is wanting to
get into like what you're into I think
that's like a really good opportunity
for like you to bond but it's also
really sweet because it's showing like
oh like my person's trying to get into
what I'm doing like they want to support
me in that absolutely it's a very nice
thing to do and like I said he's trying
to get her into competitive games is a
terrible call yeah there are a lot of
people who complain about that that
girlfriends are what I've been not
playing video games and this dude has
the option for her it's like it sounds
like she's repeatedly said that she's
interested and he's like yeah I want to
[ __ ] you up in Smash Bros and if you're
not good enough at it you don't get to
play Animal Crossing comment on it for a
bad and go play something like Detroit
become human yes it sounds like this guy
so we have anything else
talent-wise going on in his life and
this is the one thing he has over he
lords over everybody else he really
likes playing video games as a personal
thing and that is the one point in which
I'm going to defend him is there a sin
games where I think I've had this
conversation with people that I've dated
where I've been like wow we could play
it together and they're like no I don't
want to do that VG's and stuff that
makes sense I think that you're allowed
to have those games that you choose for
yourself and if Animal Crossing is one
game that he's like I've been so excited
about this this whole [ __ ] time I
just want it to be a personal experience
then I get way he's coming from also but
wow did you phrase it all Paulie yeah I
don't think that's where he's coming
from no good because he's mostly talking
about her in efficiencies rather than
being like this is really personal to me
and I've loved this series my whole life
and I just want to experience it by
myself I it I get that pot but of course
she doesn't get that it's a gaming which
grinding and planning is key he's just
yeah she's gonna ruin the lavishness
thing with her huge [ __ ] I also still
think he's the [ __ ] though because
then he he's like I offered to but I
make more than her so I offered to buy
her a switch and the game and she's
still upset and he's like yet because
that's not the pole
yeah yeah this thing with you it's also
like that seems really cute like the
idea of putting it on a switch dock and
playing Animal Crossing together on a TV
and like showing on how it works nice he
could have just not said any of that and
then felt that way and then have gone
out and bought her it and took it as an
opportunity to bring her into the
passion like that's what I would just
[ __ ] dial back and be like actually
I'll buy it for you since you're crying
now no it sounds like this dude thinks
that his girlfriend is an idiot and he
kind of doesn't want her to get involved
in video games for some reason is how it
sounds to me it's funny when I have the
tweet up here I can see you'll reply
here Ross that says this can't be real
oh yeah yeah
so there's another person responding to
Melanie Mack been friends with who said
it's not everyday the new animal
crossing game comes out I don't think
it's wrong of him to want to play on his
own
I've been hyped for room Factory full
special when it launched they wouldn't
wanna split my time with my husband
playing and it's okay have your own
things total you do agree I genuinely
think it's alright you can have things
to yourself don't be a piece of [ __ ]
about it so god damn mean dude